we have big news to talk about today we
we sort of are moving from to make this
an analogy to sort of a chess game we're
moving from the mid game to the endgame
and in the fiasco that is the Donald
Trump presidency JA Donald Trump is now
privately expressing concern that he's
going to get impeached now to be clear I
already know that if you're at rumpus
you're going to call this entire story
fake news so don't even bother just skip
it don't even bother writing to me about
it I know that you're not going to
believe anything about this report now
for everybody else let's actually talk
about what's going on there's a new
report with multiple sources which tells
us that Donald Trump privately is
expressing concern about being impeached
when Democrats take over the house in
January of 2019 when it comes to why
Donald Trump thinks he'd be impeached
it is only related to the campaign
finance violations connected to Michael
Cohen's felonies and guilty pleas Trump
does not think that he will be impeached
for so-called Russian collusion or for
obstruction of justice or any of that
stuff he believes it will be an
impeachment solely because of the
payoffs to former mistresses felonies
which Michael Cohen participated in
committed under the specific direction
of Donald Trump now Trump likewise
seems to understand that the house
merely brings the impeachment forward
ultimately it would be up to the Senate
to vote on whether to remove Donald
Trump from office Republicans of course
hold the Senate they're going to
continue holding the Senate in 2019
Donald Trump does not think that
Republicans would vote for his removal
except that there's another story from
Capitol Hill today which I'll talk about
next which might make us question that
assumption assumption but I agree with
Trump in a sense which is that if the
only incident at issue is that of the
campaign finance related felonies that
Michael Michael Cohen pleaded guilty to
which we know that he did at Donald
Trump's direction I agree I don't think
that the Senate a republican-controlled
Senate is going to vote to impeach
Donald
Trump on that basis the more pressing
question is do we really believe that by
the time it's all set in the undone by
the time Robert Muller is finished here
that those felonies committed by Michael
Cohen at Donald Trump's direction are
going to be the only thing that we're
going to have on Trump I don't think
that that's likely it doesn't seem that
Donald Trump actually knows the full
scope of what Muller has on him right
now the campaign finance felonies will
be nothing if we end up with evidence of
Trump trading promises of sanctions
relief to a foreign power in exchange
for help defeating Hillary Clinton and
we haven't even gotten to all of the
obstruction so if Trump's position right
now is based on the idea that only the
campaign finance felonies will be at
issue I tend to agree with him he's not
going to get impeached over that the
question is what else will be know by
the time it's all said and done the
obstruction Fiasco as an example is well
documented in the public domain
never mind what investigators have which
we just don't know yet at this point I
don't know what Trump's smocking to take
a vocabulary word out of his recent
tweets I don't know what from smocking
if he thinks mistress payoffs are
ultimately going to be the only issue
here most of the Democrats I've seen
interviewed so far Pat understand this
is not the time to talk about
impeachment a couple of Democrats have
talked about it I think it's a strategic
mistake I believe at this point what
Democrats should be saying about what
are you going to do once you take over
in January focus on what they want to do
for the American people when they take
over talk about what they want to
investigate the investigative power of
the house is powerful but let the facts
lead them to impeachment if ultimately
they will rather than talking now about
any plan to impeach Trump yeah I
certainly think that most Democrats
recognized that it would be a bad idea
to impeach him knowing that they
probably couldn't get him out of office
that they couldn't get the 67 votes
needed in the Senate and also if it was
over something like campaign finance
violations related to a mish
Triss pay off like a very similar thing
happened with Bill Clinton in 98 he was
impeached for lying about a sexual
affair this is kind of similar right
it's the same kind of scope and scale
and I don't think they're gonna want to
repeat that mistake no I think you're
gonna they're going to need more and I
the one area where I disagree is if they
have more on Trump by March 2019 June
2019 even if it's not something that
would get Republicans in the Senate to
act to remove Trump I actually would be
okay with filing impeachment with moving
forward with impeachment in the house if
it's the right thing to do I just think
that it's going to be a tough one to
move forward on if all we have is these
Cohen felonies which Trump directed but
I am confident that there's going to be
more I would be shocked if there isn't
more by the time it's all said and done
but the one thing I'm not mentioning
here yet is what if Republicans do
decide that they're sick of Donald Trump
and that's what I want to talk about
next one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an incredible online
learning community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between
I think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took a really great class on graphic
design which I know nothing about but
I'm trying to learn our show is giving
you two entire months of totally free
access to every course Skillshare offers
risk free if you click the link under
this video you'll have two months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share that passion and after
that you can keep getting access to the
entire site for less than ten bucks a
month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up